it is our understanding and i confirmed
that a man known as jake davison aged 22
had murdered a woman at an address in
biddick drive using a firearm
i will not reveal that address
as we are still contacting the members
of the family of the lady who has died
we will reveal that address later in
more detail for you
mr davidson then left that address
entered biddit drive where he
immediately shot and killed a very young
girl
he also shot and killed the male
relative of that girl
this was a truly shocking event
and was witnessed by members of the
public
further along buddhic drive
he aimed and shot at two local residents
a man and a woman who've received
significant but we understand at present
not life-threatening injuries
they are currently being treated
at a local hospital and supported by
specialist officers
again there are witnesses to this
from there mr davidson entered adjacent
parkland
where he immediately shot a man who died
at the scene
and thereafter he moved to henderson
place where he shot a woman who despite
the best endeavors of first aiders at
the scene later died
at derriford hospital
eyewitnesses have told us that then mr
davidson turned the gun upon himself
taking his own life
you